multi-agent system modeling mir
thanks sanjeet and thank you for the
invitation
uh yes i'm actually at the university of
gothenburg but the department is shared
and this is joint work with abdul rahman
who is still in gothenburg and giuseppe
pirelli who is in rome
and thanks here for sharing your slides
with me
and this work is supported by the erc
project
the cinema so um
so we have seen um
several talks about uh single agent
reactive synthesis especially burns
um burns tutorial was very insightful
and the high level idea is that we want
to automatically produce a reactive
system from some high level description
of desired behavior
and for example we have a acute robot
walking around
the the ales of this of the supermarket
and we want to write something high
level like you know
you should walk around the ales avoid
all obstacles that you find and if you
see
spot something that is missing you
should notify a manager or do something
else about it
and the general idea would be that we
take this
um english or
or in some kind of um well-formed
english or semaphore semi-formal english
specification translate that through
synthesis automatically to some kind of
automaton-like
program and then this is deployed
automatically to this
cute cute robot here and the robot goes
around
and patrols the supermarket
and the idea is that this is a lot more
flexible than
just programming the robot by yourself
and actually this uh to a high
level of to a high level of confidence
this
somewhat works and i think one of the
nicest applications of of how this work
has been
in robotics and um by no means this is a
that's this is an exhaustive list of
people who have been working on this but
uh people that i personally uh
like to refer to uh hadas gazette from
cornell richard murray from caltech who
took true from uh university of texas
the
the the robot that we saw in the in the
previous slide is a is a real robot in
hadas's lab
uh this is quite an old system from
richard murray but richard murray still
uh works with synthesis as far as i know
and um they actually take
specifications in ltl or fragments of
vertical
and walk them through synthesis combine
them
into uh active uh robots
and produce uh very nice results and
there are other applications of of
single agent synthesis and here i'm just
mentioning so things that i'm aware of
so
there's definitely a lot more but i
worked on model driven development there
are people working on
how to use synthesis in adaptive systems
i think maybe
roderick's work can be described at a
high level as uh
working in design of adaptive systems
uh industrial automation and um
and many many more so a lot of people
are working on
taking single agent synthesis and making
it um
work in practice and there's a lot of
interesting work
uh to do there uh roderick's talk just
now was a was an excellent example of
that
and um
if we look on what autonomous reactive
programs are
um i started by talking about um
well this this cute robot and
when we tack autonomous programs and we
think about for example the
the autonomous car and how it would run
on a highway
then things start getting a lot more
complicated
and this view of singular agent
synthesis
may not generalize very well so
for example for the highway in the
highway case people i think for example
sanjit had worked on this how to take
single agent synthesis consider
all the others as uh as a as adversarial
and the the framework of scintillate
single agent synthesis can be sort of
stretched
in order to cover uh what was required
for a car
to um to drive on a highway
but if you look on more complicated
scenarios for example uh
a junction like here so if you want an
automated junction
what would it mean for a reactive agent
that we want to synthesize
to be able to cross such a junction what
would be uh the
what kind of features such an agent
would be required to have and
and even the junction although it is
very very complicated
it has a major difference from this uh
picture of these
three robots called coordinating and
collaborating to lift a chassis together
and the main difference from from my
point of view is that
in the junction at the very least each
one of the agents
can capture its own goal and the goal
can be expressed
in terms of the view of g agent but if
we go into
a collaborating system like these three
robots together this is no longer true
no
one not no single robot can even grasp
the joint goal
of holding this this thing together and
turning it and continuing the
the production so things are becoming
a lot more complicated but we still
want to do this and the idea here is to
start looking on what are the features
that we would need to support if we want
to
model such systems and
i think roderick mentioned distributed
synthesis
and this is the the way we usually refer
to synthesis when it is applied
to um
okay so sorry i'm this is actually the
first time that i'm
presenting on zoom from powerpoint i'm
used to presenting from pdf so certain
things are
just not viewable here anyway
uh yeah so we refer to distributed
synthesis as
the problem of controlling multiple
devices together with disjoint
strategies or disjoint programs and
usually we
people who come from my background they
think about
how do these subsystems communicate and
they think about shared variables
but from a very very early stage it was
known
already by pinulian rosner in the 90s
that if we have
uh this you know such distributed
systems and we have
disjoint inputs and disjoint outputs
it's very very easy to show
that um the question of whether we can
synthesize systems
is undecidable and um
in the tutorial by by bernd if if you
watched he already
already mentioned that we can do some
things
if we restrict the kind of architecture
of
combination of these systems but the
complexity gets very very high uh
very very fast and he did mention
bounded synthesis as a possible approach
to bypass the undecidability and bypass
some of the
of the high complexity and this is
actually
the reason if i remember correctly the
first introduction of bounded synthesis
was
uh in order to solve distributed
synthesis now some other people uh
when they think about synthesis or
distributed synthesis would think about
uh other ways for uh subsystems to
communicate and this includes message
passing for example the
the work on on discrete event system
control
uh use messages for synchronization um
from my point of view uh the kind of
interaction that is allowed by message
passing
is kind of limited in the way that uh
control is shared between the system and
the
environment but that's usually my
problem
and there's a lot of nice work on
control of message passing systems
if we're talking about uh the long
automata another approach
uh for thinking about how subsystems
communicate and and coordinate then
um it is well known that more
architectures are this are
decidable for example work by uh anka
mushroom and igor walukiewicz i forgot
what the gg are
and it is still the case that for the
longer automata borderline of
understandability is still
very unclear and um
[Music]
yeah the borderline of unstability is
still unclear and
this is a promising area for for
research
what we try to do here is again to think
about
the features that we would
that in our opinion an agent would
require in order to
participate in one of the scenarios that
i highlighted before
and the answer was we would need a
combination of transfer of data
synchronization and when an agent works
on its own it needs to have a
it needs to be well defined on its own
and we try to take these elements from
the three models that we talked about
before shared variables message
communication synchronization
and go one step backwards and think
how would we use this for modeling and
model checking
in the context of monolith checking this
builds on work uh uh lumos yoku raymundi
that is based on concurrent game
structures by allure hensinger group
from
nvadi uh in a tool called uh model
checking
multi-agent systems or the work by
woodridge gutierrez and hernstein and
many many follow-up work by in in the
group of michael woodridge
on reactive modules games and
um yes so
looking on how would you do modeling for
this domain and how would you model
checking
and we suggested the formerly the
formalism that we called
a recipe for reconfigurable
communication programs
and essentially we're supporting multi
multiple types of communication that
allow to reconfigure communication while
agents
are um are acting
and the interaction is parameterized to
the evolving state of agents and let me
try
to explain how this works so we have a
basic
building block that is an agent each
agent has its own state
it has send and receive transition
relations
and a system is a collection of agents
and
they interact based on communication via
broadcast channel
or multicast channels essentially by
sending messages what's special here is
that every
uh message has a condition
telling us which agent this is uh
this message is intended to and here for
example the
message is intended for green robots
and the green robots on their hand will
have what we call receive guards that
will tell us
whether they're connected or not
connected to channels and this robot for
example will be connected to the channel
c
when it is green and uh once a
communication goes through between
agents they
may change the state by according to the
transition relation and here
uh they were both green and they turned
uh
orange and yellow because they were uh
applying different transition relations
this one was sending and this one
was receiving and we support two uh
modes of of interaction one is um
a non-blocking broadcast and essentially
uh for example this yellow robot here
wants to send a message to
green or orange robots it will target
them
with some messages that has
some data here uh the yellow robots are
so the the robots that receive the
message
change their configuration to tilted
based on
when they receive this message the
yellows are no longer interested so i'm
just
deleting them uh from here and then this
communication could be followed
following the state change by further
communication for example between the
the orange robot and the other robot
orange robot
following a state change and again
leading to a state change and if you
notice what happened here is that
the yellow robot managed to recruit two
[Music]
two orange robots and might be doing
something similar
uh with the greens later so that's uh
based on broadcast
uh multicast um is
in contrast is blocking so here for
example the yellow robot wants to
send on channel c some message uh it
wants to send some
message that uh whose condition is this
formula
here these robots are
not connected to the channel so for this
communication
they're actually not interesting and in
order to pass
the message all the robots that are
connected to the channel
must satisfy this condition and in this
particular case this
orange robot is not ready it doesn't
satisfy the specification and we
have to wait with the sending of the
message until something else happens to
this robot it
changes a state and only then the
message can go through so these are two
types of communication i'm
somewhat short of time but we define
the dynamics of this using transition
systems of two types
and we started thinking about how do we
do linear time reasoning about
about this in a way that will include
information about the rich
transition labels that that we have in
the system namely the messages and
the channels that they're sent off and
the conditions that are used by
by agents to to send messages
and essentially we extend ltl with
complicated next operators that allow us
to
refer to the intention of the agent so i
want to send the message to agents of
type
green and orange for example is
something that we could say
and this next operator can be
[Music]
embedded into larger and larger uh ltl
formulas leading to
essentially reasoning about the
interaction protocol
um in a way that captures some of the
rich
labels and transitions that that appear
here
we have the expected automata theoretic
results so
uh model checking is in p is in p space
this is uh
this is unpublished we we improved this
after the paper um
after the paper appeared in the
conference
and uh and we reduced the complexity to
to p space and um
yes and to conclude
um at the moment we're working on
sort of modeling and model checking and
the
the idea is to proceed to um to
synthesis to distributed synthesis
um as the next step
uh but the motivation here is to
consider distributed systems
how they operate and what kind of
communication
such systems would have to do in order
to collaborate
in junctions or by lifting things and
yeah so we suggest the formalism that
allows to reconfigure
uh communication while agents are are
operating
um and we extended the ltl to reason
about uh
about the messages and who's sending
them the and the intentions
of agents that that
send these messages we're currently
working on
tool support for both the modeling
framework and
model checking we are considering uh
how should we reason about distributed
execution
should be these be um normal executions
or maybe
masochievic traces and partial orders uh
what kind of logics should be
tailored for reasoning about such
executions and our goal is to proceed to
think
what can we do for distributed synthesis
given
such rich communication models thank you
thank you nir
um are there any questions i saw there
was a hand raised momentarily
any questions from the audience
okay if there are any questions please
put them in the chat or the q a
and thank you later again um
let's oh i see radhu you have a